in real life was sunny a good man
meaning when you're you're
robert kiyosaki writes a book rich dad
poor dad yeah he says my dad was uh poor
but i met this one guy that played the
role of my dad and it was a rich dad and
my dad followed all the rules got the
degree got a regular job but this rich
dad was a business guy investor real
estate all this other things and i
followed my rich dad not my poor dad
right right
when you look at the life between sunny
and your pops
was sunny
good for society
was sunny a good man was he doing the
right thing sunny you know that's what
makes a bronx tale so different and so
why people want to see it sunny was
telling me exactly the same things as my
father
you have to realize that
this is not good fellows good fellows is
brilliant a movie as it is they wanted
the kid to be a bad guy
sonny was saying don't be don't be like
me do something with your life
make you if you've got talent do
something yeah now i i thought about
this as i got older i could be totally
off but i always thought that i was
sonny's penance
in other words he was saying to himself
if i'm going to do one thing that's
right in this freaking world yeah i'm
going to make sure this kid don't go
under interesting you know now that's my
way of seeing it just to be clear are
you talking about the character or are
you talking about real life oh real life
real life
yeah well he says in the movie
all your friends you're hanging out with
they're half of them are going to have
to they're in jail
that's the what that is my actual
favorite scene in the movie where he
grabs them out of the way he grabs them
out of the car that's what the ace and
the other guys actually look up to
someone like hey sonny we're going to go
do this
if i ever see you with these guys again
i mean that's powerful things that he
says if you're a tough guy he goes you
think having a gun makes you a tough guy
yeah he goes it's when the other guy has
a gun now we see what a real tough guy
is and you go oh wow he's right about
time yeah you know what i mean and but
the thing about sonny was
he wasn't black or white he was gray and
my father was great
so it was these two forces interesting
gray versus gray gray versus gray not
black versus white yeah it wasn't evil
and good they were both they both had
great qualities
but
the bottom line is sonny was a killer
sonny would kill you you know but he was
a great guy and he was funny
people are not just so that's why robert
cole and the moral intelligence of
children talks why children go but why
children study a bronx tale because they
go well but wait a minute but sonny
wanted him to do well
and what robert cole was saying in his
book
he goes sometimes e good and evil is not
so easily recognized it's not so
delineated you have to look at it and
study what's behind it and that's what
makes bronx tale so different chaz
what's great about your dad though what
was great about your pops my dad which
which was incredible was i couldn't tell
my dad even though
he was on the bus he he loved he worked
with
with black people and he was kind to
them and wonderful and they loved him
because he would always talk to him and
he always helped him he didn't want i
knew he wouldn't but it would bother him
if i dated a black girl
i knew it would
i knew it would
and i think the reason why
it was a product of the times 1968 it
was insane in 1960 race riots race riots
rock kennedy got assassinated
mother king
i think when i got older i asked him
that question when i got older i said
dad you know i did date a black girl i
said why he goes i know you and tell me
he goes i figured you were and i said
why were you upset about that why you
don't like that he goes i was afraid for
you
because of my love for you that i didn't
want you to go through that had nothing
to do with her but in a way it did he
says i just as a son you don't want your
child to go through what he's about to
face
so i understood that where sonny was
different he was like hey black white
what's the difference go ahead
interesting
morality yeah morality so so with with
you being do we have the clip with rudy
or no the the clip uh do you have that
when he talks about the italian family
or no
uh uh
ky you're looking at me like a doctor
like you're confused yes no maybe
you do have it or you don't have it
kyle i'm just happy with that
with his glasses no joke you look like a
professor at
harvard maybe wharton business school
that's what
oh what
are you going for what carl from
accounting is that what it is you got
the look it's it works it works for you
pat that gray area thing that's very
interesting is that what attracts you to
the mod for your genre i i think
business is great i think business is
great i think leadership is great i
think parenting is great i think
i think it's very hard for a
black and white person to make it in
business i think it's very hard for a
black and white person
to make it in many different industries
because here's a challenge like you know
how he talks about the whole twenty
dollars uh the bronx talent and you say
the hundred thousand dollars with me
it's not the hundred thousand dollars
it's the fact that your mind is consumed
with the thought of that guy that has
your money yeah that sucks your energy
out right so the great part
if somebody's in the grade they
understand it they're like part of the
game i got to move on the black and
white part is you have to go get that
money back
you know because you're so stuck on the
principle of the fact versus the grace
like let it go you need that energy put
it here make 10 million rather than
trying to consume so much time
so no i think on the business side by
the way you learn great the hard way you
don't learn at the right the the the the
the easy way it comes with experience
that's not something that you can read
about
black and white at one point and then
you had to like that's a black and white
guy my dad raised me
uh uh
you you met my dad my dad is very you
know
strong personality that he has but he's
got a sweet side this is the sweetest
guy yeah
but but let me tell you my that's a high
standard guy it's like you know
you say one time to him you're gonna do
something i swear to god if you don't do
it he's gonna call you a hundred times
about it but i had to learn on the
business side you
it's very complicated so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]